hello everyone perry here back on the
channel and i feel like my guest needs
no introduction because you all know how
obsessed i am with scream skeet alright
hello it's so nice to meet you and let's
get into it so
wondering what your first conversations
with wes were like about the role
basically what were some of your
earliest burning questions before
jumping into the role
uh i you know i i don't specifically
remember
i mean it's so long ago to be honest and
i'm sure there there were some but i
know you know there was a concentration
on the psychology a lot and
um
and i think we both had the instinct to
lean into
[Music]
kind of pointing the finger at billy
you know in the beginning so that the
audience would
think uh no there's no it's too obvious
there's no way
um
and i just sort of you know was focused
on
the psychology of a killer and
only that
and so
i i'm sure those conversations revolved
around that and how to i know he talked
to me a bit about you know the reason he
cast me was because
i was believable as a sweet kid but i
was also believable as a crazy kid so
whatever that's worth
so i'm going to assume that wes never
spoke to you at the time about
billy's parents specifically his mother
so if that was the case what was it like
for you watching scream too and knowing
that laurie metcalf was your mom well i
haven't seen two three or four but i did
know that yeah
i didn't know that from the first one i
had somebody i had heard it from
fans at conventions or something more
recently i don't know i just never never
watched them
so it's like still to this day you've
never watched them i haven't so i like
to binge watch movies so i'm waiting i
have to have four
movies in a friend so once five comes
out all
i'll watch two three four and five how
about that i wanna i wanna revisit this
chat then and i wanna i wanna get your
opinion on all those other movies i i'm
sorry i wish i had more to offer
i'm so curious though um
going back to your own though
yeah let's ever discuss with you who
killed who between billy and stu i feel
like over time we've all kind of pieced
it together and maybe figured it out but
did you two have to know who was
responsible for what and when
uh nobody ever knew to be honest
there were no conversations about it i
mean i you know uh
i know that you know
for you know and insurance reasons etc
like the
you know the ghostface had to be a
stuntman
um
but
yeah we didn't really we we didn't know
and it never really was part of the
conversation
now though you know going to conventions
and stuff i hear like it's a big burning
question and people have theories and
have figured things out and
yet you know
i know
matt lillard had a conversation with
kevin williamson and he never
thought out who who was doing what so
[Laughter]
i guess that's kind of speaks a little
bit to the genius of wes you know his
ability to sort of
you know that
that people feel like they have clues in
there as to
who is who and i think some are more
obvious than others in hindsight
obviously
if i'm
appearing right after it's clearly not
me so
power of a franchise like this i wes was
chris was very good at that and just you
know inspiring uh inspiring a fan base
out there it's kind of fill in the gaps
that are really there but not
necessarily on screen
yeah yeah and that you know only really
become part of it if the film
works well enough to have a 25 year life
or whatever you know that you know had
this movie not you know reached an
audience in the way it did
we wouldn't be having this conversation
i'm glad i didn't love this franchise
one more question about wes for you
cause i was listening to another
interview that you did where you said
that
wes would say just like one little thing
to you and it would make all the
difference in how you played a
particular moment so do you have any any
specific examples that come to mind of
that happening and it changing your
approach to a particular scene in the
movie
i i mean i don't remember you know the
exact exchanges per se
but um
i you know i do remember you know
there were little nudges you know little
that were just almost whispered
as you walk by and it it
from my recollection most of it had to
do with
trying to instill a reaction in the
other person so
um
you know as a way to shape billy but
through
what he was trying to achieve in in the
other person so um
but he was so psychological like you
know and so clear in each character and
their role in in
in the overall orchestra and
uh and kind of a tone master so
uh anything he had to offer you know you
always wanted to deliver whether it felt
instinctually correct to you in the
moment or not like he was that clever
very understandable
do you have a favorite matthew lillard
one liner in this movie
yeah of course
you hit me with the phone dick
so is is all that is all that scripted
is it scripted that you i was not it
wasn't scripted that he gets hit by a
phone it wasn't rescripted that he had a
reaction to it i you know i was venting
at having lost i think sydney at that
moment or where
knowing where she was and
the fake blood was so sticky then when i
went to throw the phone just in
frustration it didn't go the direction i
intended
and it
what you see it hit him and and his
reaction was in the moment
um so yeah that's that's my favorite
because
he's still [ __ ] about it
very very understandable here here's
another like very specific line i want
to ask you about it's after uh it's
after uh billy and sydney have the
conversation before she goes into into
the bathroom and she leaves and you say
stupid like my whole family repeats that
word exactly like you say it whenever we
just say that word casually in life so i
watch a scene like that and i'm thinking
like maybe that's a beat that's not
scripted as well because the scene could
have cut there but ultimately i'm glad
it didn't so was that particularly in
the script originally i can't remember
to be honest it felt pretty like in
trying to remember it as you say it i
feel like it wasn't but i'm not much of
an ad libber so i'm thinking maybe it
was
uh regardless i i think it is kind of an
interesting moment like once
everything's revealed to re-analyze that
moment and what is he talking about
necessarily
um
but i can't i i can't remember and a lot
of times what happens is like
you know you ad-lib something like that
and then it gets written in the script
notes and then
you know it will get printed in the new
pages as having so it really you know it
may look like it's in the original
script but it really wasn't
um but i can't remember really
it's it's an interesting moment that it
always catches my ear because the
delivery is so memorable but also it's
like it's really one of the only private
moments we get for billy yeah
yeah it's true it's true
that's funny i've never nobody's ever
brought that up that's yeah you know it
always i like it it's me
all right let's do let's do a little
what if i'm just i'm wondering if you've
ever thought about what billy would have
done if he succeeded with his whole plan
because you know i watch a lot of
revenge movies and those movies often
have a line in there that said you know
like if you kill this person and get
your get your vengeance it's not going
to satiate that anger anyway so right do
you think that if he had if he was able
to see all this through and succeed that
he would have just went on living his
life as one of the few survivors or
i mean is he just bound to be a serial
killer regardless
i think the latter i think yeah i think
he would have found other ways to vent
um and to punish people for sure
uh
yeah i don't i i think if
for whatever reason it was just born
into him you know
early
prefrontal cortex damage who knows but
yeah i think he's a serial killer
through and through
yeah i'd believe that all right
getting the last question so let's go
with
i mean one of my favorite sequences of
many in the movie is is the the kitchen
sequence the the third act so it's it's
a pretty elaborate set piece with many
beats in it so if you had to isolate one
particular part of that that was the
most difficult to pull off which one
would it be
uh
that's a good i mean there's a
particular
beat inside of you know the reveal of
his motives and
the heartbreak of his parents
you know falling apart i think trying to
you know because of the elevated energy
and stakes and and being on a 10 the
entire time performing that scene for
five days or five nights as it
was to get that one scene
you know trying to switch to that
heartbreak in a way that isn't sappy
but feels sort of
raw and
uh is you know was a was a particular
focus of mine that
you know i think we got i think you know
it's it's there but it's not
off or
and there's a little bit of a rawness to
it that kind of
makes you feel for him a little bit
that was always sort of the goal was
that for you know
that
you try and get an audience on your side
and no matter whether you're playing the
good guy or the bad guy so
that's the challenge of a part like that
and was the first time i was playing a
part like that so it was uh i was glad
to have wes to guide me through that
great success in that respect it's very
involvement in that scene
i have to let you go you're you're lucky
we were reduced to 10 minutes i got like
25 years worth of questions here oh no
i'm gonna circle back and get you
eventually but big thanks for chatting
with us today and thank you congrats on
one of my favorite movies of all time
thank you so much thanks for the
question
you